joueur yannick et xavier merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur sur rt france
adore déjà comment vous vous recevez
cette nouveau confinement jusqu'à la fin
du mois de mai bonjour à tous j'ai déjà
remercié rôle mersiol par vous de nous
permettre de nous exprimer en fait cette
nouvelle mesure est mesuré que l'on
accueille avec beaucoup de on estime que
c'est une maladresse que c'est malvenu
masque aujourd'hui ce n'est pas cohérent
avec la situation réelle du pays
c'est cohérent avec la situation du pays
qui a égalé la situation en ce moment en
guyane aujourd'hui en guyane sur deep
left her say qui sont dans les écoles
200 dans le milieu professionnel et un
dans la sphère familiale mais on se
refuse de fermer les écoles
aujourd'hui les tout ce qui est non du
travail demande qui est des mesures
d'accompagnement si la fermeture mais en
reparle de fermeture sans mesures
d'accompagnement
donc aujourd'hui c'est en un total des
connexions avec ce qui se passe et ne
parlons même pas de l'état de nos
frontières qui sont des passoires
aujourd'hui n'importe quels voisins
surinamiens brésil hier ou autre du
continent le sud africain peut rentrer
par nos frontières sans contrôle réel et
quant au contrôle le formel c'est à dire
notre héros whaou
il n'y a aucune mesure quand vous
arrivez en juin pour contrôler votre
certaines ou de vous donner les moyens
d'assurer cette certaine
donc on est vraiment dans un dans un
bricolage aujourd'hui au niveau
préfecture rs on ne sait pas quel saint
se vouer
le rectorat négrière alors que
aujourd'hui le plus gros vecteur de
contamination c'est l'école et quant aux
élus locaux
c'est même à ce qu'ils disent donc
aujourd'hui la population autrement et
sur un ras-le-bol
une colère qui ont une grande et donc on
sait pas comment ça ma structure mais
aujourd'hui cette nouvelle mesure de
smic en fumant année rien en moi parce
que certains vont travailler d'autres
pas on va fermer le week-end et la
semaine tout le monde allait travailler
tout le monde peut aller à l'école
donc ya pas de cohérence on le disait un
tout à l'heure le nombre de malades en
tout cas le nombre de cas positifs
augmentent un en guyane plus de 80% je
le rappelle des balades sont infectés
par le variant brésilien la proximité
avec le brésil particulièrement touchée
puis comme vous le disiez ses frontières
particulièrement pour eux selon vous
sont les explications à l'augmentation
des quarts en guyane que sa première
fois que ça parce qu'aujourd'hui en fait
plus de prévention c'est à dire cette
prévention c'est dans l'analyse
dauman analyse tous tout explose ces
contaminations parce qu'elle ne va rien
de résigner comme tout virus par le pas
sur les russes classiques il voulu ça
c'est normal mais derrière les moyens de
prévention autour de cela
c'est à dire de faire l'analyse ou
comment où et quelles difficultés
rencontrent pour pouvoir s'y
reconstruire ce variant mais voilà on a
ri à quelques belles dents qui avaient
parié au sud africain en guyane eh ben
on se doute bien qu'il arrivait par
l'arrière
donc ça veut dire que quelque part en
elle il ya quelque chose à faire
il ya des mesures à prendre et qui ne
sont pas c'est aujourd'hui une ville et
rs ni l'art effectué ni le rectorat
ni les autorités locales préconise bon
on parlait aussi également tout à
l'heure de la vaccination en métropole
de plus en plus de métropolitains sont
sont ou se font vacciner ces derniers
temps à contre le cofidis
9 quel est l'état de la vaccination
justement chez vous en guyane et lui
accès très faible tout simplement couru
une raison que l'on veut pas prendre en
compte
malheureusement la médecine
traditionnelle aujourd'hui induit un la
médecine traditionnelle a fait ses
preuves sur pied des domaines mais en
soros on se refuse aujourd'hui malgré le
laboratoire de l'institut pasteur qui
est l'un des mieux sur le continent sud
américain
si d'américains parmi elles on se refuse
d'étudier cette possibilité d'être
soignés ou faire de la prévention avec
les plantes les gens et la médecine
traditionnelle locale dont home ou des
guyanais se soigne par la médecine
traditionnelle
où sont la prévention à la médecine
traditionnelle donc ne vont pas se faire
vacciner parce qu'ils estiment louis
xiii fut tout d'abord resté sur un
principe de médecine traditionnelle
aigles si les mendiants les résultats du
fiabilité bastia ça aussi une question
des victoires et fiabilité de ce vaccin
sont démontrés plus que raison là je
pense que l'arrivée d'un échange mais le
problème c'est ça c'est que deux au no
men médecine traditionnelle qui a fait
ses preuves qui a déjà oeuvré sur biais
des nouvelles et de l'autre il ya le
doute de cette population guyanaise
quant à l'efficacité réelle de ce vaccin
pour la ram et vous parlais justement de
cette défiance un des guyanais sur sur
le sur le vaccin vous parler d'eux
de médecine de médecine locale justement
est ce que cette médecine dont vous
parlez a fait ses preuves dans la lutte
contre le coc vie 19 ha oui oui il ya
plus d'une personne aujourd'hui il ya
plus de des centaines de personnes qui
vous disent aujourd'hui qu'ils ont ils
été positive
ils ont suivi des traitements à base de
plantes à base d'huiles essentielles à
base de deux médicaments fabriqués et
pas ceux qu'on appelle les grands chez
nous parce qu'ils sont des sachets qui
connaissent et qu'ils maîtrisent ce
qu'on appelle le on va dire la posologie
au niveau des plaintes et ben ils ont
guéri et ils ont développé des immunités
ce qui fait aujourd'hui leur système
immunitaire est beaucoup plus résistant
et il retombe pas mal sauf que nos
autorités locales en désir sur les yeux
ne veulent m'en reparlent et la halle à
l'aise sous la sourde oreille quand en
préfecture avait une botte en touche
nos élus locaux ben 10 suivent le
mouvement dans sa fac et c'est compliqué
derrière payer proche de lui à l'est qui
insistent et 10
il faut aussi faire valoir et mettront
dans cette médecine traditionnelle comme
à cuba on leur demande à ce que vous
demanderez à l'instant où ils ont
développé un vaccin en interne avait la
même chose
larrieu pourrait démontrer sa sa
capacité aujourd'hui à développer un
traitement concernant la wii
merci beaucoup a indiqué xavier d'avoir
été avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
merci d'avoir répondu à vos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
général du syndicat union des
travailleurs guyanais merci beaucoup